[Music]
hello i'm jen wilson senior programmer
with film independent presents and
welcome to this q a for the new nat geo
documentary film we feed people by ron
howard special thanks to our lead
sponsor
the hifpa and vision media who host all
of our virtual screenings and q and a's
now please welcome today's guests from
we feed people producer sarah bernstein
and editor andrew morial you're going
through very high water is the only way
to be delivering food i'm so glad that
we have this track i hope we are able to
feed the people but they hope we are
going to be safe for me it was very
clear that i wanted to create
organization
that we will be able to respond to
events that disturbs the lives of people
i am jose andres we are here with a
simple mission
to make sure that food is an agent of
change in a crisis you call on the
experts no one was calling on the cooks
and chefs of the world when there were
people who were hungry the emergency has
this amazing way to speak to you you
only have to listen
you can listen to the situation
we can listen to the wind
we can listen to the people
sarah bernstein is a huge celebrity to
me
um
i
i
i've been a i've been a programmer for a
long time
i was
a programmer for ellie film festival we
program a lot of your documentaries i
did q and a's for a lot of your
documentaries but never with you
i know so excited that you you're
actually here with one of your
documentaries this time
um
so uh sarah you started i don't know if
you started with hbo but do you want to
talk about just because we have so many
um up-and-coming
aspiring filmmakers
um in film independence membership do
you want to talk about how you started
your career in in documentary
yeah no i'd be happy to and and thank
you so much for saying that um just
about like all the great projects i've
been able to be part of over the years
and i'm such a fan of film independent
the la film festival holds a special
place in my heart and you know just love
all that you and the organization have
done over the years to to really promote
um
documentary films narrative films and
really up-and-coming filmmakers so so
thank you this is really special for me
to be part of this
um yeah as as you mentioned jen i
started hbo almost um
20
plus years ago at this point i was at
hbo for almost 20 years and now i've
been at imagine documentaries for almost
four
um but i am
it was kind of the first real
i should say like kind of steady
position that i had after sort of
freelancing for a few years straight out
of college and i was lucky enough
to um to be welcomed into hbo i started
very briefly in the limited series
department and then
found my way
to sheila nevins the great sheila and
evans and hbo documentary films or
sheila found me i should say and was
able to really
kind of build a career there and as you
mentioned just work on you know probably
hundreds of films over the years and
often with first-time filmmakers and
andy and i collaborated quite a bit
during
my time at hbo
and it was um it was an incredible
incredible experience and a few years
ago i was approached
by imagine entertainment which is ron
howard and brian grazer's company to
launch a new documentary division
for the company which was kind of
expanding as more of an independent
studio and it was such a great
opportunity
that i just couldn't resist so it was it
felt like the right time to kind of
embark in the next phase of my career
while at the same time a very
interesting kind of moment in just i
would say kind of the proliferation of
documentary programming across all sorts
of streaming platforms
and
you know just new avenues of
distribution so it's been an incredible
experience a whole re-education for me
but um
i'm really proud of what we've been able
to launch over the past few years at
imagine
awesome thank you for that sarah
um
for for andrew how did you get started
in documentary editing
oh wow
um i guess i always i was a film buff
when i was a kid i always had the super
8 camera um i got an internship out of
college with a small documentary film
company called open house films with
mark open house who had done a lot of
like pbs stocks
and i just got to know that whole circle
of people that at the time
that was the place to go that was the
only place that we're making documentary
films outside of doing like indie stuff
there were televised documentaries so i
worked there for a couple of years and
gravitated towards editing and then had
an opportunity to work on
a spin-off of the famous brain series on
pbs and it was called the mind sort of
like a psychological version of the
medical mind film
and got into the editors union through
becoming an assistant film editor
it was really great because i learned
how to really edit
from
a lot of the guys that were working in
film we met both men and women in film
and actually cutting film
and um so i really saw the change in the
technology and i was really fortunate to
be able to to see that sort of firsthand
in that process and that that discipline
of storytelling and then just got you
know as the as the as the technology
advanced i just kept kept on and i
realized that my passion was in
storytelling in the edit room
more so than out in the field shooting
so
let's talk about this film we feed
people um
i have to admit i i mean i
i'm not i'm not a big um
food television person so i only sort of
knew who jose andres was
but um i went um
a few weeks ago to the uh silent film
festival in san francisco
and one of their screenings was a
tribute to world central
they were donating funds to world
central ketchin because
the filmmaker was ukrainian
and um
and world central kitchen has has an
effort going on in ukraine right now to
help help um survivors of the war
there
um and so that was really kind of the
first time that i had thought about jose
and thought about world central kitchen
and thought about the you know sort of
this idea that really this guy has given
up his entire career
in order to put all his efforts into
this so i'm just wondering um you know
how
uh sarah and andrew you were introduced
to
the subject matter and um why you wanted
to tackle it as a
as a film
yeah well i i'll just start because on
behalf of imagine imagine documentaries
um our company that produced the film so
this really started with ron howard you
know our our incredible director and he
was
you know we were we had wrapped up or or
had premiered um his previous net
geo documentary rebuilding paradise and
that was uh just to backtrack for a
second we we started producing
rebuilding paradise right as we launched
imagine documentaries back at like
almost the end of 2018 and perron who
had produced you know
countless number of
feature films and tv and you know just
one of the most successful creative
directors out there
he had
started to direct a few documentaries
most of which had been sort of
personality driven projects like
pavarotti where you have a very
well-known subject and a life story to
really tackle but he had not yet really
kind of dive into sort of the world of
verite as us documentarians you know
live and breathe or most of us so
rebuilding paradise if you haven't seen
this to the audience um please check it
out i think it's streaming on hulu and
it was another partnership with nat
geofilms who also partnered with us on
we feed people but that was ron's sort
of first kind of you know
entree into that world of verite
filmmaking and i think he was he really
loved it um
he was really kind of struck by just the
the sort of um unpredictable kind of
nature of it not really knowing how a
story is going to end and i think we
were we were trying to figure out what
would be his next documentary and what
could be another verite experience but
also one i think that really centered
and focused on an issue that could be
important both to ron but certainly to a
larger
audience even global audience and around
that time when we were thinking about
his next project he um
had encountered jose and he had met him
at several events over the you know the
past couple years and at the same time
world central kitchen was just starting
to get sort of real kind of national
attention
and we we started to take notice and
certainly ron did that wow jose really
was growing this organization and it was
really becoming sort of a prominent ngo
well how did that happen and maybe there
was a story there that we could kind of
explore
so
ron reached out to jose
jose was
interested but he was also very clear
that
world central kitchen isn't just about
him right like world central kitchen is
an organization and a network made up of
many people many volunteers many chefs
many people in the restaurant industries
all over the world
and for him it was really important that
the film sort of focused on that
and i think for ron he was really really
interested in this idea of volunteerism
like what would
make somebody sort of drop you know
maybe what they were doing
professionally to go you know
donate their time to a larger cause
and that's sort of what led us on this
path we sort of you know tried to assure
jose that you know we would try not to
totally focus this documentary on him
and we were lucky enough to find just
incredible supporters and partners in
national geographic documentary films
who jumped right on board as they were
also interested in what was happening
with world central kitchen and jose
as a personality
so that's how the project got started
i would just say that for me
it was really crazy because i had worked
on a couple of imagine projects i did
the dad's film with bryce dallas howard
and you know they're very good the
imagine team is very good at being able
to pair the right people for the certain
projects
but i think meredith or sarah had said
to me oh you know here's a list of some
things that we're thinking about you
know
what do you what do you think of these
ideas usually they say that but in this
case they said
we have something that you think you
would be interested in i don't know how
much they knew about my background in
terms of volunteer work but like my
wife's a social worker i volunteered for
the red cross i run a music charity
event to raise money for local food
pantries so it was like this is perfect
and the interesting thing was in all the
volunteer work that i've done
you never really you never really saw
the leader of that organization you'd
see the need
and you'd see what you know what
volunteer circle of people you can bring
together to help facilitate that need
feed people whatever the case may be
and in this case i i was fascinated by
this one man and the origin story of him
and saying well you know he's the one
that inspired people to want to go and
volunteer
wouldn't that be an interesting story to
tell especially coming from the
background of me seeing
all these very
very willing people going and doing
giving of their time to volunteer to
help feed people so so it was perfect it
was like a great connection i was very
excited to be able to do it
so
how many uh this is the the infamous how
many hours of footage question
how many hours of footage did you have
to get through to get down to your
feature length yeah
well
we
at first we started to look at some
stuff um
early and uh
well late 2019 we just had like an
exploratory like couple of weeks where i
was gonna look at some stuff
before any shooting was gonna happen
have conversations with ron and and
everyone on the executive team um
hopefully they would bring a producer on
at that point but they wanted to know
like well you know we got all this
archival so between what we got and me
not even realizing how much was there in
initially but between what we got and
what we shot which we did shoot an awful
lot as well it came out to about 1100
hours of footage
and i you know had there been 1100 hours
from the beginning i probably would have
run for the hills but since it was like
things were coming in and we actually
tapped a lot of the archival material
that that world central kitchen had and
then we shot you know over time
obviously on and off during the pandemic
um but ultimately it was it was it was
1100 hours
well
and also
you know to andy's point i mean it's an
incredible amount of footage but i also
think when we started this project and
certainly when andy first joined
we weren't even sure
or it wasn't clear to us at that point
just how important that archive of
going to become because as andy said we
started this process in 2019
we very much saw the film as an active
verite embedded scenario we were waiting
for the next disaster call that we would
get or that world central kitchen would
get that then our team could jump on
board get on the ground and just start
running with
and obviously what happened is what
happened to many productions over the
course of you know 2020 and certainly
2021 is that
coveted happened it took us a beat to
really figure out well how do we manage
a production during covet can we even
shoot they were you know off and running
in um international locations which were
not going to be easily
accessible to an american crew at that
point so it was it was um quite
fascinating
to be able to kind of switch gears and
sort of you know just in terms of how
ron and we all felt about the direction
of the film and obviously andy was such
an important part of that evolution
because
once we realized that there was a real
archive that really traced the evolution
of world central kitchen from a
grassroots kind of scrappy organization
to this you know much more sort of
powerhouse um you know
i don't know what you'd say like kind of
systematic sort of you know not polished
but you know certainly a much more
well-oiled machine of an organization as
you see them today once we realized we
had almost 10 years of archive footage
we thought uh okay like we have a film
and we have a film that will really sort
of
um you know present that trajectory to
an audience in a way that would be very
valuable along with obviously the
original shooting that ultimately we
were able to do during covet
one of the
the conflicts that
there are several things that emerge
from the documentary i mean not
not overtly but of course you know
uh situations like these are going to
become political on their own
and
one of the things was really interesting
was um
the little conflict that he had in
puerto rico with red cross
um
which you know i'm not trying to call
out red cross nobody's trying to call
out red cross but it sort of brought up
this issue of
a ton of people trying to come in and
help and they're being like kind of
chaos or
and so uh i'm just wondering for me for
me i'm wondering um
why it was in particular that you wanted
to show that particular conflict
i mean i think it's important to show
you know the reality of the challenges
that that jose and his team had and i
think you know you can say oh there's a
bureaucracy in place and you know if you
just cut all that red tape you can we
can get a lot done but there's also this
concept that you have to coexist within
the framework of that bureaucracy and
the politics that are involved
and
what i found the most fascinating about
puerto rico i mean aside from my
politics and how i felt
what i knew and how you know
our government reacted to helping
americans in puerto rico
was how it helped jose realize that he
was going to have this uphill battle so
it was a perfect dramatic
turning point in the arc of the story
that that led us down that path of like
he's going to be met with resistance and
once we knew that then we could say what
is the other resistance that's that that
he followed so like right from the
get-go as soon as we saw puerto rico and
having read the book and knew a lot
about what's going on in puerto rico we
were absolutely convinced like that was
going to be the political story
that was going to be the beginning of
the political story because
it's it had all those challenges and and
you know maybe it wouldn't have happened
if anybody walked in and jose is a guy
that like big and brash and he was a
doer and he wanted to get things done
but like you know he jumped on the train
the train was half moving and like he
had to learn the system and then
ultimately create his own system
yeah i think what's you know what's
interesting is jose is a big you know
he's a big personality and um
i think um
without him having to directly say it
the film sort of
comes together to say
um
you know where's everybody else in this
like what you know
when are all these other people that
have all this money going to help when
are our leaders going to help when when
are we going to figure this out i think
it was interesting because like
rebuilding peridot you know rebuilding
paradise brought up a lot of those
questions too like this is climate
change and fires are here to stay like
disasters are here to stay
and we need to figure this out and i i
felt like the same thing was happening
with this film
yeah um was that one of the reasons that
you wanted to make it was was
not only that jose is doing this but
jose clearly has a message for people
well i mean i think it was sort of an
interesting discovery too along the way
right because i think as andy said
he you know he starts off in haiti and
he's sort of ignorant to any system
right he just is a man who wants to help
and a man who seemingly has resources
and then i think you
we get to puerto rico and
he's a man who wants to help but he's
also
a successful entrepreneur and he's sort
of determined to get on the ground and
really be able to mobilize
and as andy said he's sort of surprised
by in a way how much he has to bump up
against that red tape and that
bureaucracy
and then i think you ultimately see him
move
into um advocacy
and policy almost and toward the end of
the film you see him you know certainly
during covid he's talking to biden he's
talking to kamala harris
he's talking to nancy pelosi i mean he's
talking to you know anyone in government
who
might pay attention and maybe those
people are also being you know political
right like they they understand that
this is sort of an avenue that maybe
they can help sort of push open and you
know whatever those motivations might be
but i do think that
he's he he has understood by the end of
the film
that his organization is only one
organization and in a way it's sort of a
band-aid organization right and that
there needs to be a much more
systemic change with how governments
respond to these types of disasters and
i think at this point the organization
while still doing you know
what their core kind of you know
philanthropy really is and you see that
right now in the ukraine i think there
is also this other path where they're
trying to you know organize
a greater sort of political movement
around sort of food sustainability in
the future
so that i think is really really
interesting and that is something that
ron was particularly um
fascinated by because
i do think you see sort of one man
kind of make a difference you know even
if it's sort of it takes him a decade
and and he goes through his own sort of
personal transformation along the way
um but it's truly inspiring and i i
think this is sort of where world
central kitchen will move into i think
they will become sort of a more
unifying um ngo force
yeah it's crazy how these documentaries
like really
you know point out what a meritocracy it
it still is like are you deserving of
help does the work is has the world
decided that you're really deserving of
help it's one of the reasons why we
would never just feed everybody that's
hungry in los angeles because certain
people are deemed
uh you know people who are drug addicts
and um
have drug and alcohol issues we judge to
have put themselves in that situation so
we wouldn't help them for free right
yeah um
and it stands out so much you know who
we decide deserves to have help and who
doesn't
um
and i think jose's message is
everybody deserves to have help if
you're hungry everybody deserves to have
help
um
so what's so what's the update
on jose and world central kitchen do you
know what's going on i know he's in
ukraine
do you know where all he's at these days
i mean
i know that they are in and around the
ukraine you know
quite aggressively at the moment i think
they are also in other places i mean
they were obviously just in texas after
the horrific school shooting
i think they
they continue to mobilize and go where
they're needed and it's it's really
incredible and i know we don't have
anyone from the organization on this
call but it's a small team of people who
are able to mobilize an
incredible
kind of community on the ground in these
locations
i i didn't realize right there with them
i didn't realize they um
responded in instances of
shootings in the united states that's
incredible
i mean what's really interesting is that
goes back to why they're such an archive
too because
and in a lot of cases
they were the first boots on the ground
so they're actually getting the intel
and distributing that intel to not only
the world but to within their
organization as to what the needs are so
there wasn't just a need to like let's
document what's going on because we want
to post this on social media to pat
ourselves on the back it was it was so
that we could prove that this stuff is
going on and that there needs to
continue to be an effort to come and
help and so
that sort of documenting of what's going
on and seeing and making people more
aware it just makes the world smaller
and it and it allows for hopefully
future change
yeah that was going to be my next
question is is what what do you hope is
that is the outcome in this documentary
and
as as filmmakers that are in
you know i'm a big fan of silent cinema
especially the progressive area which
there's hardly any of those films left
but
um you know
films that were
made by by people who thought that you
who saw film as the avenues for cha for
massive social change just wondering if
you
sort of subscribed to that belief as
well
i mean i for me it's you know it goes
back to something so simple that ron
said early on which is that if like if
this film can do one thing
and get people off their couches to go
and volunteer
and it doesn't have to be world central
kitchen it could be a local food pantry
it doesn't even have to be like fighting
government local government whatever it
is it's just like everybody needs to be
aware that there's a need and that they
should
step up when
when and if they can and if that
that's that's what i care about most
that the that this film can influence
that that that mobilization of people
that wouldn't normally do it to do it
great
yeah but to answer also your your kind
of larger question i mean i have to
believe that
this is where films and particularly
documentary films remain valuable
i think if you can just you know as
andy's saying if you can convince one
person because they tuned in to we feed
people on disney plus or on hulu
which we just heard it's also going to
run the
film
i think if if just a couple of people
who knew nothing about world central
kitchen all of a sudden started to pay
attention
to the organization or just to the idea
of
hunger as an issue or sustainability is
an issue
then the film did its job and i think
entertainment can have enormous impact
and especially
um films that you know that really focus
on on the human experience it's not just
about you know talking heads feeding new
information but that you're actually
sort of experiencing what people
experience and walking in other people's
shoes i think it's the way we can
increase empathy in the world
uh yeah to to your point about it being
on disney plus i i have proof that that
people noticed your documentary by being
on disney because my mother told me the
other day she she went on there to watch
one of them
she went on there to watch one of the
star wars shows
and clicked on your phone because it
looked interesting so bonus
that's great um we wanted
it next to ob1
thanks mom
um
when is it gonna be on hulu is that um i
just heard that it's going to start
streaming on hulu soon so i think it's
not a big date but i think it's imminent
yeah well congratulations to the two of
you it's a really inspiring and powerful
film
and um
i know that that you both will be on a
lot of documentaries again in the future
i hope that i get to speak with you
again thanks so much for coming today
thanks for having us thank you
[Music]
you